one of the reasons that high
companies like Saturn and others often
don't get carried on is that once the
founders leave the next generation of
leaders don't carry on the same
practices and so the culture goes back
to more traditional organizations but
there are ways to address this issue by
building commitments to multiple
stakeholders right into the bylaws of
the corporation let's look at some
examples we'll consider three different
models first let's talk about what we
call benefit corporations benefit
corporations build right into their
charter three different objectives first
they say they are going to commit to
producing results that are good for
their shareholders for their employees
and for the economy secondly they are
going to consider financial and
non-financial considerations when making
key decisions that allow them to keep
the the benefits flowing to all of these
stakeholders third they agree to be
transparent
they provide annual reports on their
performance and their progress in
addressing the interests of these
multiple organizations one of the
best-known companies that is a benefit
corporation is Patagonia Patagonia is
this very famous clothing maker and its
CEO and founder Ivonne Jannard says
Patagonia is trying to build a company
that could last a hundred years benefit
corporation legislation creates the
legal framework to enable mission-driven
companies like Patagonia to stay mission
driven through succession through
raising capital through changes in
ownership in doing so it
institutionalizes the value of the
cultures the processes and the high
standards that are put in place by these
founders so by doing this we get some
continuity in fact 22 states now allow
companies to incorporate as benefit
corporations within their boundaries and
we have at this point about seven
hundred and eighty six such companies
another option is employee ownership
you've probably heard the term ESOP
employee stock ownership programs
well employee ownership
companies build a commitment to being
successful financially both for
traditional investors and for employee
owners right into the structure and
governance of the firm employees often
have representatives on the corporate
boards of directors but the key to the
success of these companies is to make
employees feel like owners by building a
culture of engagement of ownership of
encouraging employees to make
suggestions for improving the operations
and the performance of the organization
and therefore aligning the incentives
through compensation and through the
culture of the organization so employee
ownership companies have spread across
their country there are about 10,000 of
them and you can find them in almost any
industry that you can think of the key
to employee ownership though is to make
sure employees are involved and to also
worry a bit that they don't put all of
their financial resources for retirement
into the same company you also want to
spread your investment a bit so that you
don't come up short if the company
happens not to be as successful as you
would like there are other kinds of
companies called cooperatives a
cooperative is a company that has lots
of owners that pool their resources to
get some job they all need done done
together so if you happen to grow up on
a farm you may have been part of a milk
cooperative where farmers pool their
resources and create a dairy to take the
milk from their dairy cows there are
sawmills in Oregon here in Cambridge we
have a MIT co-op and the Harvard
co-operative society book stores that
sell books and reference material and
clothing to our students and to our
faculty and then there's my favorite
cooperative as might I suggest it's the
Green Bay Packers Green Bay Packers are
a community owned football team started
in the 1920s and how else could you have
a city Green Bay Wisconsin with only
about a hundred thousand residents
sustain a very successful
highly competitive and often
championship football team for all of
these years it's because they are owned
by the community and they can't be sold
to some higher bidder who might make a
profit off of it you also see some
cooperatives in other countries probably
the most famous one is the manga set of
industries headquartered in the Basque
region of Spain with companies that
range from manufacturing to retail to
high-tech to financial institutions they
have over 81 different companies at the
moment so we can build organizations in
different kinds of ways and so the
takeaway lesson that I hope you will
have here from this conversation is that
it's possible if you are imaginative
perhaps you can invent the new forms of
organisations for the future that will
meet the needs of all of their
stakeholders and would be will be built
to last for multiple generations and in
doing so not only might you build
organizations that work for investors
customers and employees but maybe ones
that helped to sustain our planet
you